Researchers have discovered how to reuse paper
by creating a printer that uses water instead
of ink so the print fades within a day.
And Korea is planning to build a new 1.23
billion dollar city that will include a theme
park and hotels....
FOR ROBOTS.
Vsauce!
Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
Scientists at the Albert Einstein college
of Medicine were able to see how the brain
makes memories using advanced imaging techniques
by tagging memory molecules in a mouse model
with fluorescent tags.
Eyes On glasses let you see through skin to
get to veins.
Evena Medical created the glasses that work
by pulsing four different kinds of light into
the skin and then combining it into a single
composite image.
This gives healthcare workers a clear, real
time, anatomically correct image of the veins
beneath the skin to reduce issues like multiple
needle sticks.
The AKA24 is a future driving concept featuring
a magnetic road you drive sideways on next
to a traditional road.
Designed by Chuang Dong and winner of the
Michelin Design Challenge drivers can choose
to stop controlling their vehicle and instead
ride the maglev-like railroad system.
Once connected to the railway the car is flipped
on its side into the undriven position where
the driver would rotate to stay upright.
This robotic ankle mimics the muscles, tendons
and ligaments of the lower leg.
A collaboration between Harvard University,
USC, MIT, and BioSensics have developed an
orthotic device to help those with ankle and
foot injuries.
It uses pneumatic artificial muscles and soft
materials that are able to act like real muscles
by expanding and contracting but work is still
being done to make it wearable for patients.
Peanut allergies have been essentially cured
in 9 out of 10 kids with a new treatment that
gradually escalates the amount of peanut protein
the body can handle.
Glyph is a mobile personal theater.
The virtual retinal display uses one million
micromirrors in each eyepiece and projects
images directly onto your retina creating
super sharp imagery.
Users can connect to their personal content
library or stream movies from a smartphone,
and even use it for gaming.
It can also be used as an audio device and
worn like headphones and all you have to do
is pull the visor down over your eyes to start
the visual display.
Researchers at MIT have created a wearable
book that makes the reader feel the same sensations
that the characters in the book are feeling.
It uses 150 LED lights and a series on sensors
attached to a vest worn by the reader.
During scary parts the vest contracts around
the chest and waist, vibrations occur during
exciting passages to raise the heart rate,
and somber moments trigger soft dark lights.
This new device is designed to harvest energy
from your organs.
The piezoelectric device has been created
to constantly recharge pacemakers and other
implanted devices.
It's sewn directly onto the heart, lungs,
or diaphragm because those organs are in constant
motion.
The device has nanoribbons made of lead zirconate
titanate which bend slightly as the organs
move creating small amounts of energy to power
the implanted device.
Triton is an oxygen respirator concept that
uses an artificial gill model.
It extracts oxygen through a filter in the
form of fine threads with holes smaller than
water molecules.
Just by simply biting on it, the user is able
to breath for long periods of time underwater
just as if they were on land removing the
need to learn how to use complicated scuba
equipment.
Vigo can gauge your energy level and tell
you when to nap.
The wearable device monitors your alertness
throughout the day by tracking patterns in
blinks and your body's movements so that it
knows you're drowsy before you do.
And it can also make suggestions on how to
change your routine to be the most efficient
based on your average level of alertness over
the course of a day.
Finally, Antimedia created a reel of footage
using Cinedrones - an aerial camera system.
I'm gonna leave you with Rynocycle an electric
unicycle - and as always - thanks for watching!